we got the best bets of the week coming
up Michael since you're older and not as
handsome as me I'll let you go first go
ahead tell me your bets of the week or
in other words you have no idea what
your best bets are gonna be I want to
hear mine from are we gonna ping-pong or
you want to hear all mine I think I want
to hear all yours I do I am cuz you have
no idea what you're gonna do you have
five games starred that I know that I
wanna bet on I don't know which three I
want to pick I'm kind of filtering them
out as my brain as we go right now so
you want to hear mine before you figure
out yours rights that my friend is
[ __ ] okay
all right fine we'll ping-pong them then
does that make lettering pong all right
go ahead you're the first thing I'm pong
go ahead go ahead all right I got the
Giants I got the Giants they're given
what two three points
the Giants it's it's Danny deuce time
baby he's gonna drop a deuce all over
Washington they're gonna be stirring
Gatorade with a plunger by the time
Danny deuce is done with them I like the
Giants that's one of my best bet oh my
gosh you're Dana I don't even know what
to say there I cannot believe it he's
gonna drop a deuce on you for picking
them like that okay my first bet of the
week that I like this one there's no
doubt about it the Colts I'm going with
the Colts over the Raiders even though
it's a seven-point spread that 1 p.m.
East Coast game I think the Colts with
their offensive line their D line verse
that Raiders offensive line that's a
little banged up really scares me
I think the Colts dominate the Raiders
and win that game by more than seven
points yeah you know what that probably
should have been one of mine but I've
already locked mine in and I'm not gonna
let myself be influenced because I've
heard yours I like the Cowboys on Sunday
night against the Saints although I know
the Saints have that strong desire to to
get a little measure of revenge for what
the Cowboys did to them last year
I think the Cowboys are too good on both
sides of the ball we're given the Saints
too much credit for beating the Seahawks
in a fluke setting look that there's a
reason Drew Brees is one of the best
quarterbacks of all time
Teddy Bridgewater played well last week
but it wasn't spectacular 265 yards of
offense to more than 500 gained by the
Seahawks I still don't know how the hell
they lost that game right so I like the
Cowboys to cover in this one that's one
of my best
that's Bukit yep I I doubt mad at you
that one I don't have the guts to make
that a best bet but I don't think that's
crazy uh it's better than your Giants
one I'll tell you that much okay all
right my bet next best bet of the week
I'm going with the Seattle Seahawks who
are favored by five at the Arizona
Cardinals but I have no faith in the
Arizona offense I have no faith in their
run game when you become one-dimensional
against the Seahawks and Pete Carroll
that always scares me
I think the Seahawks will be pissed off
with the fact that way they lost you
just mentioned to the Saints last week I
don't have a ton of faith or anything
special about that Cardinals defense
either the Saints very balanced I mean
the Wrentham and the Seahawks very
balanced okay on the offensive side of
the ball the Arizona Cardinals will play
man-to-man that'll play right in the
hands of Russell Wilson and him being
able to make big plays down the field so
I like the raid out of the Seahawks
sorry I can't say this damn game right
Seahawks 3117 in the game that's one of
my bets of the week I think the Seahawks
are gonna be desperate and know they
have to keep pace with the 49ers and the
Rams in that tough division they have my
text already so I'm not stealing your
idea I like the Seahawks too I think
last week was an aberration they're
gonna be pissed off the Cardinals are
not good enough there's enough film out
there the defense is gonna figure out
how to shut down air Kingsbury so I
think the Seahawks win this one and they
win it easily yeah so I agree with you
okay all right now this is where I'm not
sure where I want to go here okay you
got my two my third one I'm like little
between the bills the Chiefs and even
the Houston Texans who were at home
against Kyle Allen and everybody I'm
very conflicted with what I want to do
there but ultimately I think with Darius
slay not being a hundred percent and I
don't trust the Lions pass offense yet
I'm going to go with the Chiefs I don't
think the Lions are made to play this
type of football game little scared with
this one but it's the least one I'm
scared of out of all the other ones I
mentioned I just think the Chiefs
defenses turn the corner I think it's a
solid unit you're not gonna just be able
to just march up and down the field on
them anymore
and the Chiefs offens of course we know
is special and I just don't know if
there's enough special on the Lions
defensive side of the ball to slow it
down even though I think a lot of Matt
Patricia so I'm going the Chiefs to
cover that six and a half point spread
because I think they're gonna win 31 21
and there's our best bets of the week
those are the ones I feel most
comfortable about
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports